it's time for our scene and unseen
segment we expose the stories behind the
headlines and for that we turn to Fox
News contributor Raymond Arroyo all
right Raymond do you remember when Joe
Biden said this
how do you think things are going at the
border sir
much better than much better than you
all expected
it sort of gives you the sort of what
well
yeah I love how he's laughing it makes
you feel that he's on to something that
you don't quite know Laura well it turns
out we might be right the
democrat-controlled Senate passed a
defense bill that requires the
completion of the border wall using
materials rusting along the southern
border since the Trump Administration
you'll remember we showed our audience
much of that from the sky but as the
house considers the bill the Biden
Administration has been quietly selling
off those wall materials at auction talk
about unseen they've unloaded more than
half of the 300 million dollars worth of
border wall parts for pennies on the
dollar Laura I think this is called
defying Congress or undermining
democracy as you mentioned earlier in
the show well maybe we should since
we're giving everything away to Ukraine
maybe we should just send the border
wall over there and they could drop it
on the you know on the Russian troops I
mean at this point I mean it's just you
don't expect you know anything to go
right for these people it's just
Insanity well that may be that may be
the only way to get that border wall
built you'll and I love this I just
found this out today Biden spent two
billion dollars on storage for these
parts that he's selling for pennies this
is really disgusting but Laura I want to
turn to politics for a moment at the big
GOP debate on Wednesday MSNBC apparently
wants the GOP candidates to go after
Donald Trump hard
if they don't go after Donald Trump then
they're not really debating they're
either running for vice president or
they are hoping that he disappears in
illegal fog none of these people are
going up on the stage Wednesday to offer
Americans something different
they're offering something different
from Joe Biden and I love how MSNBC that
has been hoping and praying that Trump
disappears into illegal fog is now
chastising others for hoping he
disappears into a legal fog whatever the
case there's a lot of smoke being blown
at MSNBC I don't think you can take any
of this seriously I think Ronald
McDaniel and all of the candidates
should take notes every time like a
MSNBC panel comes up I mean when you
hear them speak take notes because they
have your best interests at heart right
just do the opposite and you'll do
you'll do just fine meanwhile over at
CNN mild Panic has begun to set in there
as they encounter polls showing Biden
and Trump neck and neck within the
margin of error
look at these one point one point if you
go back at where we were at this point
four years ago Joe Biden's lead was high
single digits to low double digits so
this idea that Donald Trump can't win
the general election I want you to lose
that idea Donald Trump is pulling better
right now than basically at any point
during the entire 2020. that's
fascinating
that's fascinating that's stomach
turning for that that's funny
the faces lord they're like that's
fascinating oh uh very interesting let's
go on to Lady Gaga morning yeah let's go
let's go on too what happened with
Taylor Swift at that wedding over the
weekend they were just exactly
but you know Laura I I was looking at
this over the weekend CBS News may be
way ahead of the curve they dropped what
could be the biggest Story of the Year
and few noticed CBS posted this tweet
Friday read it closely former President
Joe Biden holds news conference talk
about a scoop Laura they later issued a
correction but we will be watching for a
follow-up on this breaking news story
former President Joe Biden imagine that
no CBS of all people the Tiffany Network
Laura yeah that's one of the good
moments I love that
yeah okay finally it was revealed this
week that while the squad was urging
everybody to defund the police and
trying to limit second amendment rights
guess who spent more than 1.2 million
dollars in campaign dollars on private
security Corey Bush spent more than 736
thousand AOC nearly 273 thousand your
friend ihano Elon Omar 125
000 and all of this on top of the
taxpayer-funded security detail each of
them enjoys from the Capitol Police this
is Rich watching this this uh these
numbers come out and by the way this is
all Federal Election Commission figures
that the New York Post their hands on it
so this is disgraceful well but remember
regular people shouldn't be able to
defend themselves right they shouldn't
be able to like you know can carry
concealed or anything
they're fine because they have private
security to the tune of several hundred
thousand dollars in some cases but the
regular person just to go into urban
America or some mall and they should
just be defenseless so by the way Corey
Bush's Corey Bush's private detail
they're supporters of the Second
Amendment and Advocates of it and that's
who she's hiring to protect her I mean
the the double play the hypocrisy is
outrageous and nobody even covers this
story well I'm glad we had time to now
Raymond their death these people are
definitely that work for them in the
private security they're not like soy
boys or you know pajama boys these are
real people who get it done okay so
they're real they're real security
people and they're all for the Second
Amendment all right Raymond thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else